tom carrick asks well it says
fascinating are there overlaps with the
field of quantum biology what about orc
o.r that is i'm sure you've heard of
stewart hameroff's and penrose's
orchestrated objective reduction
yeah
um
i don't know
i i can't say too many useful things
about that but but i will say sort of
one thing uh
i i
do agree with uh with with uh hammer off
and penrose on the idea that anesthesia
in general is
one of the most profound
maybe maybe the only profound tool we
have to study actual consciousness right
that's we don't have a lot of other
tools to study consciousness but
anesthesia is a pretty good one and the
interesting thing about anesthesia is
that in general most general anesthetics
are gap junctional disruptors now this
this this has uh like many uh facts this
as things that are that are easy to
understand and some things that are
deeply puzzling the e the kind of uh
thing that makes perfect sense is that
these these electrical networks in the
body uh
manifested various cognitive abilities
long before they were brains so these
gap junctions that enable body cells to
form networks are critical for these
networks to have memories memories of
body shape but to make decisions about
what they're going to grow and so on so
so the use of gap junctions to
make networks that can follow
large-scale goals like make a limb and
make an organ and so on that's
evolutionarily ancient and it's not
surprising at all that what evolution
did when the nervous systems developed
was to use that same trick to create
another type of cognitive agent which
which lives basically central ascension
centered in the brain and used the exact
same reuse the exact same hardware for
that so that makes sense and and so it
makes total sense that that goes away
when when uh those gap genders are
disrupted by a general anesthetic it
also makes total sense that if we want
to turn
a planarian
into it into the head of make its head
turn its head into uh the head of a
different species of planarian guess
what we use a general anesthetic called
octanol it's the exact same thing it's a
gap junctional disruption so what you're
doing is you're basically disrupting
that proto-cognitive agent the
collective intelligence of the body that
normally remembers how to make a
particular kind of head you're basically
disrupting that with this general
anesthetic now the amazing thing about
general anesthetic is that any of us
ever come back from it being the same
person think about it you have this
brain
you have you have right it's a it it
supports the cognitive structures of a
very complex creature and then
for some number of hours you simply
disconnect most of the cells from being
electrically
in communication with each other and
then you let the connections reform
and you just sort of hope that
everything comes back to how it was
right if i didn't know
you know if we didn't know that the
general anesthetics work somebody were
to tell me that that's their plan i
would say well you might get a living
living human out of it at the end but
certainly not going to be the patient
that walked in you you know you could
bear no resurrection yeah of course
you're going to completely wreck their
mental state and and so
so one thing that's amazing is that
actually most people come out of it
being the more or less the same person
as they went in
but the other interesting thing is not
everybody so in fact um there is this is
why they don't give they don't like to
give general anesthetic if they can help
it because some people have permanent
psychosis some people um in fact many
people have hallucinations on their way
out um out of it that eventually resolve
as the brain sort of finds its its
attractors that were there before but if
you watch you can go to youtube and you
can watch some really um
sort of funny videos of people coming
out of general anesthesia right and you
know people think they're pirates and
they're gangsters and they you know they
don't understand where where they've
been and they have all these crazy
stories about who they think they are
and eventually that sort of resolves
not really that part's not really
surprising i'm shocked anybody ever
comes out of it you know properly that
it's amazing
so uh the planaria is exactly the same
thing so when you disrupt their um their
gap junctions the first thing they do is
they regenerate random heads that belong
possibly to other species right and then
after about uh 30 days
those heads actually remodel back to the
correct species a species-specific shape
so
they're not permanent so so to me this
looks exactly like what happens when you
come out of general anesthesia